okay six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty let's go next to our
caller from the five zero seven area
code color from 507 you're on the air I
didn't group Bruce go ahead what's on
your mind all right I was I had a couple
of questions actually and I watched a
lot of these of your type of video on
YouTube and I think I've heard you
dismiss it before but I'm wondering if
you've changed your position on the
likelihood of the situation with the
right moving further to the right and
the less moving further to the left and
the whole thing devolve into a civil war
and if so how would you see that ending
you know would it end with separate
states would it end with separate
countries or would it end in one
fraction conquering the other again so
when you say you've seen my position in
the past and you're wondering if it's
changed what's my what's my position in
the past been on this that we're not
going to have a civil war well I've seen
you dismiss it as conspiratorial so
there's a second where I've dismissed
the idea of a separation of the u.s.
into two countries as a conspiracy I I
believe so
sounds like a different show I don't
know that that's this show but listen I
mean my view is I don't think it's
likely that the US will separate into
two countries a couple of reasons why
number one is that the liberal states
are not all touching each other so in a
logical way to split us up into two
countries just to indulge this for a
moment would include the west coast and
a lot of Northeast states and those
states aren't touching so that would be
difficult
logistically but moreover I don't think
that's the number one reason why it's
not going to happen I just don't think
there's going to be the political will
for that even though you know what Pat
the truth is there's probably four to
six different countries so to speak
within the United States I don't think
we're going to have a civil war that
splits us into mold
country's yeah I don't think that any
reason to believe that and we're
especially not going to take up arms
against okay and also with with Trump
effectively ordering his doctor to you
know declare a clean bill of health to
for MD Singh that ruins his chances in
the future of a claim of incompetence in
court defense of incompetence yeah it's
funny you mentioned that because I don't
know that Trump did anything to make dr.
Ronnie Jackson say what he said or write
what he allegedly wrote about Trump's
health exam but but hold on a second but
hold on a second please
but earlier this week let's assume he
did or that he did it actually doesn't
matter
earlier this week I said that it's
actually worse to believe that Donald
Trump has been acting the way he's been
acting for the last year of sound mind
because it genuinely means he's a bad
person and or suffering from really
significant personality disorders and or
is just a completely immoral person
which a lot of people in our audience
would already suspect but I do think you
bring up an interesting point which is
the the best defense if indeed Donald
Trump was criminally involved in
collusion with Russia or whatever is
that he was suffering from dementia at
the time and you would think that yes
the dote the note from dr. Ronnie
Johnson or dr. Rocca or the statement
from him does preclude that kind of
defense in the future from Trump I think
that's true all right well thanks all
right thanks for a call very much
appreciate it great to hear from Bruce
there